Trascrizione: Paola Barbazza
Revisore: Alessandra Tadiotto
Quando Ferdinando mi ha contattato
per questo evento
mi ha detto: "Sai, ho in mente
di organizzare una conferenza
sul tema del potere dell'amore".
Io ho pensato: "Beh,
poverini gli speaker."
E poi mi ha detto: "Avevo pensato
a te come uno degli italiani da invitare".
E quindi questa è una sfida
che io accetto molto volentieri
perché io nella vita,
come diceva Ferdinando,
mi occupo di tre cose: di sostenibilità,
d'innovazione e di leadership
e, ispirato dal titolo
di questa conferenza,
mi sono interrogato
su cosa queste tre cose avessero
a che fare con il potere dell'amore.
In effetti ho realizzato che queste
tre cose hanno molto a che fare
con il potere dell'amore.
Quello che vorrei fare con voi
nei prossimi minuti è invitarvi
in un piccolo viaggio
in cui vi chiederei la cortesia e l'onore
di sospendere, se possibile,
il vostro giudizio e assecondare
questo mio invito
di seguirmi in alcune suggestioni
che non hanno la pretesa
di avere valore scientifico,
ma solamente quello
di ispirare attraverso memi
e un percorso logico
una riflessione su queste tre cose
e su cosa queste tre cose hanno
a che fare con il potere dell'amore.
Quindi cominciamo il nostro viaggio
attraversando questo simbolico,
magico specchio di Parnasso.
La prima cosa che troviamo,
al di là di questo specchio di Parnasso,
nel nostro viaggio
è l'immagine di una galassia,
di una galassia tra le miliardi
nell'universo,
tra le miliardi di galassie
che con miliardi di soli
che scaldano miliardi di pianeti
che esistono da miliardi di anni.
Io devo dire la verità:
non sono particolarmente ferrato
in materia di astronomia o astrofisica,
però non vi nascondo che quando
guardo il cielo stellato di sera
e immagino che, magari
anche ad alcuni di voi succederà,
la prima reazione che ho non è quella
di capire tutto questo che cos'è,
come funziona, da dove è venuto
e dove sta andando,
ma semplicemente di rimanere
a bocca aperta,
stupito e meravigliato di quello
che questo spettacolo infinito
ha da offrire ai nostri occhi.
Come diceva Shakespeare nell'Amleto:
"Ci sono più cose in cielo e in terra
che nella tua filosofia, Orazio".
Questo credo sia una delle cose
che risuonano dentro di me
in maniera più profonda,
non soltanto quando guardo
il cielo stellato,
ma quando penso in generale
al mistero della vita e della natura,
cioè al fatto che c'è
una generale tendenza
di difficoltà a concepire
in maniera tutto sommato confortevole,
il mistero o il non sapere.
Ci rende, in qualche modo,
vulnerabili, sensibili.
Questo è, da una parte,
qualcosa che attrae e affascina,
ma dall'altra qualcosa che spinge
a cercare sempre delle risposte,
a cercare dei modelli,
a cercare delle teorie,
di capire e di comprendere
come funziona il meccanismo
di macchine o organismi molto
complessi come l'universo e i pianeti
o anche cose molto più alla portata
di mano nella vita quotidiana.
Questa incapacità di vivere
col mistero e di non sapere
è una capacità che però,
in qualche modo,
ha a che fare con questo che,
in mezzo a miliardi di pianeti,
è il nostro.
Per uno scherzo del destino,
per un miracolo,
per un caso cosmico è pieno di vita,
e questa immagine,
anche se non è originale,
è molto simile all'immagine
che l'equipaggio dell'Apollo 8
nel 1968 vide per primo
e proiettò per primo di riflesso
verso di noi sulla Terra
nella sua missione verso la luna.
Quell'equipaggio dell'Apollo 8
era stato mandato in missione dall'ONU,
per conto dell'umanità,
per esplorare lo spazio cosmico
e per riportare dallo spazio cosmico
uno sguardo sul nostro pianeta.
Ci sono racconti e testimonianze
delle persone che hanno fatto parte
di quell'equipaggio
che dicono che per loro l'immagine
del nostro pianeta visto dallo spazio,
nella sua unità, nella sua interezza,
ha rappresentato l'opportunità
di un'esperienza spirituale
e trasformativa.
Era la prima volta
che il genere umano vedeva
per intero quest'astronave
chiamata Terra
che galleggiava al centro
della Via Lattea.
Un pianeta, il nostro,
pieno di vita che,
con l'eccezione della nostra specie,
vivono in armonia
con l'ambiente che le circonda,
vivono connesse con l'ambiente
che le circonda,
vino connesse tra di loro
e sono tutte, in qualche modo,
forma e riflesso e rappresentazione
di questa sostanziale unità della vita.
Queste connessioni,
questa rete della vita,
sono un tema ricorrente
nell'universo nel nostro pianeta,
perché qualche modo,
se guardiamo questa immagine,
che è una rappresentazione
delle connessioni,
delle linee di comunicazione attive
sul nostro pianeta,
ci rendiamo conto che la spinta
naturale a connetterci ad altro,
a connetterci ad altri,
è una spinta che a qualsiasi livello,
che sia un livello organico o scientifico
o tecnologico o semplicemente
di comunicazione,
è una spinta innata, una spinta naturale,
è un qualcosa che ci fa tendere,
in qualche modo, alla ricerca dell'altro,
del diverso e dell'unità.
Poi si può obiettare sul fatto
che tutte queste linee
di comunicazione aperta
servano obiettivamente poi
a trasferire del significato
o del senso, o della visione,
piuttosto magari semplicemente
permetterci di scambiare
transazioni finanziarie
in maniera più veloce e in quantità
più elevata o, in qualche modo,
riempire i nostri adolescenti
di una sovrabbondanza d'informazioni.
Ma tant'è che il tema della connessione
e dell'unità è un tema
che ritorna e ritorna in natura,
e ritorna anche quando guardiamo
per esempio le connessioni sinaptiche
all'interno del nostro cervello.
Queste connessioni sinaptiche
che rappresentano una rete
di stimoli elettrici che genera
pensieri e idee,
che genera possibili nuovi mondi,
genera sogni,
genera ciò che siamo e ciò
che raccontiamo agli altri.
Questa idea, ancora una volta,
di essere difficilmente capaci
di resistere alla tentazione
di mappare il cervello,
come abbiamo già mappato
il genoma umano,
senza tra l'altro capire cosa volesse
dire la mappatura che abbiamo fatto,
per lo meno non ancora,
però lo abbiamo mappato.
Stiamo incominciando a creare
delle mappe più dettagliate,
più precise nel nostro cervello,
cercando ancora una volta
di capirne il funzionamento,
di caprine, in qualche modo il senso,
piuttosto che semplicemente ammirare
il fatto che sia uno
dei miracoli della natura.
Un mondo connesso e unito,
ma una specie, la nostra,
che devo dire non ha fatto
un grande lavoro
nell'onorare questa sostanziale unità.
Non ha fatto un gran lavoro
perché nel corso della storia
sono stati tanti i muri che
noi abbiamo innalzato tra di noi,
che abbiamo innalzato tra religioni,
tra filosofie, tra etnie,
abbiamo innalzato muri alti, fisici,
abbiamo innalzato frontiere,
abbiamo innalzato muri di incomunicabilità
nelle nostre coppie,
abbiamo innalzato delle divisioni,
dei muri che, in qualche modo,
sono un tradimento e un affronto
a questa idea di fondo
di questa sostanziale unità
del nostro pianeta
e del nostro ruolo
in questo pianeta.
Queste divisioni e questi muri
vengono da un certo modo di pensare,
un certo modo di concepire
il nostro vivere insieme,
il modello di funzionamento
delle nostre organizzazioni
o delle nostre società
o delle nostre comunità,
che ha alle spalle
un pensiero positivista,
illuminista che ha, diciamo,
in qualche modo,
la credenza di poter comprendere tutto
sacrificando ciò che forse
è più importante
e, cioè, il senso dell'essere insieme,
il senso di condividere un destino comune,
il senso dell'avere un'interdipendenza
che non è semplicemente
qualcosa che abbiamo scoperto,
ma che è sempre stata là e sempre ci sarà.
Quindi la domanda che mi sono fatto
in entrata a questa conferenza è:
come possiamo conciliare
progresso e sostenibilità ?
Come possiamo conciliare
tutte queste divisioni e questi muri
che abbiamo innalzato con questa idea
di fondo di queste connessioni
e di questo senso di essere
una cosa sola,
essere, in qualche modo, legati in questa
sostanziale unità?
Come conciliare valore e profitto?
Come conciliare cose che
sembrano così distanti tra loro
e così dicotomiche
da essere difficilmente riconciliabili.
Credo che la risposta sia
nella parola "innovazione",
e cioè nella capacità di portare
qualcosa di nuovo nel mondo.
E questo qualcosa di nuovo nel mondo
ha a che fare con la possibilità
di riuscire a trovare delle vie
per conciliare questi opposti,
per conciliare queste dicotomie,
per trascenderle e includerle,
per andare oltre,
per cercare di rimodellare
il nostro modo di pensare
e, così facendo,
rifondare le nostre organizzazioni
e le nostre istituzioni.
"Più semplice a dirsi che a farsi",
direte voi.
Beh, io vorrei offrirvi,
molto modestamente,
due esperienze, tra le altre,
che mi hanno visto coinvolto
nel corso della mia vita
e che sono, secondo me,
un esempio di ciò che vorrei
cercare di comunicare.
Queste due esperienze,
che non sono due tsunami
o due terremoti,
ma se vogliamo usare la metafora,
avrebbero o hanno potuto generare
delle onde di cambiamento,
sono due esperienze
molto differenti tra loro,
ma che hanno dei punti in comune
che mi piacerebbe sottolineare.
La prima esperienza ha a che fare
con una grande multinazionale,
all'epoca avevo solamente 26 anni,
ero un giovane idealista
che voleva cambiare il mondo,
però aveva anche la fortuna
di lavorare nell'ufficio del Cermene,
una delle persone più importanti
di questa azienda
da 150mila persone in 140 Paesi.
Insieme ad altri giovani idealisti
come me, tutti colleghi e amici,
abbiamo pensato che sarebbe stata
un'ottima idea convincere questo gigante,
questa multinazionale a cambiare
completamente rotta,
trasformarsi in un'azienda
che potesse essere un'azienda
che potesse essere un esempio
di sostenibilità e di attenzione
all'ambiente e al sociale,
e così facendo trasformare l'industria
di cui questa azienda faceva parte
e, così facendo, cambiare il mondo.
Ci mettemmo al lavoro,
in maniera invisibile,
e ci facemmo finanziare
queste attività interne all'azienda
da un gruppo di top-manager
ormai vicini al pensionamento.
E' interessante questa connessione
tra questi giovani idealisti
e questi top-manager
che avevano il desiderio
di lasciare al mondo e all'azienda
un'eredità che non fosse solamente
quella di aver aperto nuove sedi,
aver conquistato nuovi mercati
o colonizzato nuove società.
Questo progetto,
che ha avuto la durata di qualche anno,
ha prodotto risultati molto interessanti.
L'azienda ha davvero iniziato
a riflettere su se stessa,
sul proprio ruolo nel mondo.
Ha cominciato ad attivare iniziative,
diciamo abbastanza alla periferia,
non al centro, non all'interno
del quartiere generale,
perché questo era un progetto
che non voleva prendere troppa attenzione
perché era giudicato un pò controverso,
era un progetto che aveva un qualcosa
di sovversivo,
anche se nel senso buono del termine.
Per fare la storia abbastanza breve,
dopo una serie di risultati interessanti,
questo progetto finalmente ottenne
il riconoscimento ufficiale formale
da parte dell'organizzazione.
Per noi era il culmine di un lavoro
durato 4 anni,
in cui abbiamo sicuramente
provato diverse vie,
diverse cose, diverse soluzioni,
e quello che ci siamo trovati di fronte
era un riconoscimento
che si era trasformato nella fine
dell'anima del progetto stesso,
e, cioè, il fatto che l'azienda,
riconoscendolo come progetto ufficiale,
ne ha ucciso il moto d'innovazione,
il moto di valori che c'erano alle basi.
L'altro esempio è quello
di un villaggio africano
con cui ho avuto la fortuna
di entrare in contatto
già all'epoca della sua fondazione
e uno degli altri speaker che verrà
tra poco è un'altra persona
che è in contatto con questo villaggio
appena fuori Arari,
qualche chilometro fuori Arari.
Questo villaggio è molto interessante
perché ha la pretesa di diventare
un modello di sostenibilità indipendente
nei confronti dell'apparato statale
dal punto di vista della moneta,
dal punto di vista dell'energia,
dal punto di vista dell'alimentazione,
di diventare un centro indipendente,
proprio perché sappiamo tutti
che lo Zimbabwe
è sottomesso a una dittatura
che tiene anche in maniera violenta
gli abitanti dello Zimbabwe.
Cos'ha di bello questo villaggio ?
Che non solo vuole diventare
un esempio per gli altri,
ma vuole insegnare a tutti
gli altri villaggi a farlo
e, così facendo,
alimentando un circolo virtuoso
in cui dal basso si genera,
ancora una volta,
una piccola rivoluzione,
una piccola innovazione
che toglie potere
alla struttura centrale dello Stato,
e, così facendo, mira a cambiare il modo
in cui i cittadini vivono quel Paese,
quella nazione.
Cos'hanno in comune
queste due esperienze?
Beh, hanno in comune tre cose
molto importanti.
La prima è che l'innovazione sociale,
dalla mia esperienza,
può avvenire e può avere successo
solamente alla periferia del sistema,
non al centro del sistema.
La seconda cosa che ho imparato
è che ha bisogno
di essere alimentata
da persone che credono
che questo possa realmente
rappresentare qualcosa di nuovo,
e questo ha a che fare con la leadership,
ci tornerò tra un minuto.
La terza è che oggi nel VUCA World,
ho imparato la parola
grazie a Kevin Roberts,
in un mondo in cui c'è disordine,
c'è confusione,
non è mai stato così semplice
poter avviare questo tipo d'iniziativa.
Abbiamo soltanto bisogno
di più massa critica
e ne esistono già a migliaia
di esempi in tutto il mondo.
Abbiamo bisogno
di un certo tipo di leader.
E qui viene, in qualche modo,
il mio ultimo passaggio
di questo ideale viaggio.
Di quale leadership abbiamo bisogno oggi?
John Keats, poeta,
ha coniato un'espressione
molto interessante
che ha a che fare con questo:
il concetto di negative capability,
di capacità negativa,
e cioè la capacità
di rimanere nel mistero
e nel non sapere come si andrà a finire
e, nonostante questo,
riuscire a conciliare
degli apparenti opposti,
apparenti dicotomie,
e ascoltando al centro del caos
e del disordine
ciò è apparentemente è caos e disordine,
ma magari sono segnali di un nuovo
che vuole emergere,
aiutare questo nuovo
a emergere e a venire al mondo.
Queste qualità della leadership,
questo modo di intendere il ruolo
di aiutare, in qualche modo,
le cose che vogliono
già essere portate alla luce
ad essere portate alla luce,
questo lavorìo
della leadership
di riuscire a portare nel mondo
qualcosa di nuovo,
ha a che fare con quest'immagine
di un film famoso,
il cui messaggio è che
non è il cucchiaio che si piega,
siamo semmai noi che ci pieghiamo
perché il cucchiaio
semplicemente non esiste,
come non esistono i muri,
come non esistono le divisioni,
come non esiste tutto ciò
che abbiamo messo tra noi
proprio perché sono idee di persone
e come tali possono essere soppiantate
da nuove idee di nuove persone.
E queste nuove idee
di queste nuove persone
possono attecchire da ogni dove,
possono nascere da ogni dove,
ma soprattutto dalla nostra mente,
dalle nostre idee,
perché "Noi siamo fatti
della stessa sostanza dei sogni",
come diceva nuovamente Shakespeare
nella sua Tempesta,
e cioè se possiamo immaginarlo,
possiamo realizzarlo,
e se possiamo realizzarlo,
possiamo raccontarlo,
e se possiamo raccontarlo,
possiamo ispirare altri a fare altrettanto
e così facendo, in qualche modo,
reincantare il mondo e cercare insieme,
magari già in questa sala
dalla fine di questa conferenza,
a comprendere che
"Tutto ciò che accade tu lo scrivi",
disse l'infante imperatrice,
"No, tutto ciò che io scrivo accade",
fu la risposta.
Quindi il mio invito in questa sede
è quello di cercare di chiudere
questo breve viaggio
che abbiamo fatto insieme
e, se avremo capito che ciò
che in fondo c'è è un'unità,
che le divisioni e i muri sono soltanto
un'illusione ottica
e che possiamo portare un cambiamento
anche a partire dal caos e farlo insieme,
scrivendo una storia diversa,
ognuno nel suo, ognuno nel proprio,
allora forse avremo cominciato
a capire il potere dell'amore.
(Applausi)